So going back to the shower handle example, what do you think secondary
appraisal would look like in this situation? Well, I can tell you from first
hand experience. When the shower handle broke off in my hand, I had a really
stressful response, thinking about everything I had to do to have someone come
in and fix it. But then, when I took a step back and looked at the bright side,
I realized just how lucky I was that the shower handle didn't come off when I
had soapy hair. I can get new shower fixtures, and I have a reason to make time
to clean my apartment. Now, this may sound like a mundane example but I think
it nicely shows, how different people respond differently to stressful
situations. And how engaging in secondary appraisal, can help to alleviate some
of the negative emotional responses we experience from primary appraisal.